is more subjectivity that's allowed in
the conversation when it comes to the
guys but then when we look at women I
think I mean I would say if you're you
know hyper promiscuous as a woman that's
not going to generate high value for you
you know if you're somebody who wasn't
raised right by your parents that's a
problem if you're somebody who doesn't
have respect for your body that's a
pair sex with emotion for me that's a
problem we can all agree on that and I
feel like it's much more clear and I
wonder if that like there's a part of me
that wonders if some of the guys not you
I'm not speaking to you directly but are
there some guys in this space who want
to make excuses for behavior that is not
character-wise so good so they'll say
and this gets into the discipline debate
a little bit discipline is important
except here you know high value is
important for all these things but not
necessarily this character component
because that's something I don't want to
do